illegal drugs are insanely insanely
profitable yeah the people over
information is beautiful created a graph
a chart to take a look at and show you
how much more profitable they are than
legal drugs so let's take a look okay so
this is in value per square kilometer
cocaine 37 million seven hundred
thousand dollars per square kilometer
that's a lot of money in cocaine rice
which is perfectly legal as far as I
know one hundred forty thousand per
square kilometer sugar cane two hundred
sixty two thousand so cocaine a lot more
expensive let's scroll down a look a
little bit and see some of the other big
ones marijuana
we love marijuana on this show forty
seven million six hundred sixty six
thousand dollars per kilometer per
square kilometer again a lot of money
what does that compare with what
potatoes are only about three hundred
sixty five thousand tobacco only two
hundred seventy seven thousand I thought
that one was kind of interesting opium
poppy again illegal a lot of money
barley is only thirty six thousand that
is a steal for barley to get a square
kilometer of barley is anything before
we jump back is anything jumping out to
you here besides that it's pretty
obvious what's going on here and war on
drugs kind stuff yes truffles are
notably absent thirdly annoyingly even
that trouble oil
I think pattern in here that you see is
cocaine marijuana and opium all also
have medicinal properties which I think
tomatoes and potatoes don't necessarily
have NATO's know what about lycopene
they keep telling me about lycopene
isn't that very good for it I've never
heard of what you don't know about
lycopene you know oh it's big on it it's
big in the tomato community you know
about your mother you must know about
like okay it's supposed to be good it's
in tomatoes they have it says it on the
hind thing anyway when you look at that
is that just an obvious example of why
the war on drugs was an absolute abject
utter you know
just pure disaster I thought to myself
they shouldn't be showing this to
farmers like they're doing a disservice
on the war on drugs right because now
the bar are you guys gonna be in the
college yeah fascinating and I'm so
interested to see what happens with the
marijuana legalization process in this
country because you know if you think
about it in all of US history there are
only three mind-altering substances that
have ever been legal right it's nicotine
caffeine and alcohol and think about the
size of those markets and think about
the fact that none of those also have
medicinal properties the way that
marijuana does and also the fact that
you know since it's been illegal for all
time essentially the only people who've
made any money in that market are
criminals now and so like if you were to
actually let real business people into
that sort of world the amount of money
that they could make first of all once
the risk is sort of diminished is crazy
and the amount and there's the size of
the market is ridiculous as you saw from
that it's illegal on the size of you
know the market or the supplying demand
is like that yeah
I'm fast I'm so fascinated so isn't the
marijuana thing particularly shouldn't
that be a Republican issue I did a video
on this last week it seems to me that
they want small government right so they
want the government out of your bedroom
out of your house out of your living
room so if you want you can smoke a
little weed and watch TV that's small
government so they should want that and
they also because they want low taxes
they want to figure out other ways to
raise revenue well you could then start
taxing the marijuana so it seems to me
the Republicans if they wanted to be
cool they could actually be cool and
keep their principles here as opposed to
just meet this being a democratic issue
where it's like yeah we like to get
stoned you know like the fiscal
conservatives who are Republican because
of that it's the fact that their largest
constituency is the religious right as
well and I think it's more sort of a
religious so what's the deal with it so
they don't want you to get stoned
because they don't want you have a
spiritual experience as either Jesus is
that
I find it something the Bible about like
don't take mind altering substances but
then there's wine Jesus what I mean I
don't know enema - interesting when I
look at it because when you look at it
it's like when you see for the first
time the chart of all the different
sizes of stars and ours is this puny
little star and then you're like whoa
all this is going on and I was so
surprised that marijuana was the biggest
one given that I always assumed heroin
and cocaine cost more than marijuana you
know high school kids four tries
marijuana not everyone's getting into
heroin exactly so what would you say to
the people that say well if you make
marijuana legal which now DC just voted
on it right the state of Washington has
it Colorado has it recreationally not
just medicinally what would you say to
the people that say well if you start
with marijuana then it's gonna be
cocaine and crack and next thing you
know your kids gonna be on heroin if it
starts with marijuana it's most likely
gonna end with a lot of marijuana very
rarely you kick it on up to the other
ones I mean people do but isn't that the
funny thing about marijuana like I used
to smoke a lot of pot I know plenty of
people that smoked a lot of pot and
there's something about marijuana I
think George Carlin said something about
like this that people that smoke
marijuana eventually usually stop by
their own volition without hitting rock
bottom or becoming criminals or doing
awful things for it like there's
something about marijuana that it sort
of resolves itself as opposed to a lot
of these other drugs that that's usually
not the case right it's like what are
the addictive properties right like to
me and this is maybe a radical view like
tobacco should be outlawed far earlier
than any of these other things because
of the capacity to become addicted to it
yeah like it's become genetic not
genetically chemically modified to be as
addictive as possible whereas it's you
know only a small portion of the
population of smokers of marijuana that
can actually become addicted to it and
same with cocaine and all these other
things so like there's also never been
an overdose of marijuana in history like
all of these things when you think about
safety when you think about
not just immediate safety like you could
overdose but also on jet like long-term
safety is it gonna give you lung cancer
or whatever else like tobacco in terms
of the drugs on this list like it's the
only product on the market that kills 50
percent of people who use it as directed
yeah but so so we need a weed Lobby the
way we have a tobacco lobby right like
is that really I mean and that's already
starting to happen there are no obvious
in DC George Carlin probably said that
joke marijuana was probably a lot less
potent I mean now marijuana is so potent
I you know I can't abide by that
completely you know fair enough
[Music]